hi there Steve Kaufman again and next
I'm gonna change to these other glasses
that are less reflective um I want to
talk a little about the importance of
being an independent learner and and
this is one of the major attractions of
input based learning so I'm gonna stay
on this subject just did a video on on
what I consider to be the advantages of
listening and reading as opposed to
focusing on output and it has a lot to
do with the importance of being
independent because if you are worried
about your output at an early stage in
your language learning if you want to
practice output who are you gonna
practice with most people don't want to
talk to someone who can't speak very
well or who has very few words I don't
like it when someone comes to me and
says can I practice my English on you
and essentially can't say anything
I think it's an unreasonable expectation
of someone so you end up with a teacher
and again I think it's unnecessary to be
dependent on a teacher if you want to
practice your output on someone you have
you are dependent on their good will
that they are going to be patient and
they're gonna listen to you and try to
understand what you're saying and speak
slowly and and stay within the range of
the limited number of things that you
can talk about I prefer not to do that I
prefer to build myself up to a level
where I can have a conversation with
someone where I'm not a burden on them
and and you never know what their
reaction is going to be I mean some
people are patient some people are not
patient so learning by an input focusing
on listening and reading makes you more
independent and I think that is a major
major advantage I don't need to go to a
tutor I can if I want but I don't depend
on the two
and the other thing about a teaching
scenario is your traditional classroom
is one of dependence the learner is
dependent on the teacher and the teacher
decides what the activities are going to
be and I know from having been on this
list serve the community of English
teachers they spend a lot of time
talking to each other about how nice it
was that they introduced poetry or that
they brought up some subject in their
class on critical thinking which forced
the learners to question some aspect of
our society and forced them to be
critical thinkers but maybe those
learners were not interested in poetry
we're not interested in the subject that
you wanted them to become critical
thinkers of about mr. or mrs. teacher so
I think that the one of the major
disadvantages of a classroom is that the
learners are so dependent they just walk
in there and sit down and wait for the
teacher to take over the big advantage
of input but he's learning is that you
are in charge you decide what you're
gonna listen to you decide if you're
gonna spend the next hour listening or
reading or going through flashcards or
writing or if you choose to contact if
you do have a language exchange partner
you can also contact the language
exchange partner but once again once
you're depending on someone else's
goodwill you are no longer quite so
independent so I think a major major
advantage of input based learning is the
fact that you become independent and I
think that and I this is one of the
themes in my book it's so important to
cultivate that that capacity to be an
independent learner to explore the
language on your own I'm constantly
surprised at people who are as soon as
they run into the first difficulty in a
language they want it explained why is
this
on our forum now in Russian you know
yeah why are there not two dots over the
heat well it just isn't you'll get used
but a lot of things that people ask
questions about at an early stage
they eventually figure out themselves
and or again I find now that I've been
in Russia and I've been doing it for
four years now an hour a day mostly
listening and reading occasionally
reviewing a grammar book but I find it's
very useful now to go back to my
beginner books when I used to flip
through and ignore the grammar because I
couldn't remember it or make sense of it
and now I get walked through that book
it takes me probably you know between a
half an hour and an hour to go through
the whole book very quickly but I'd find
that I'm sort of confirming and nailing
down all of these rules that were
meaningless blurs to me before because
my emphasis has been building up my
vocabulary through all my listening and
reading activities and and being willing
to live with a certain amount of
uncertainty and and lack of clarity and
in the text and so now as an independent
learner I choose now to go back there
and try and nail down some of the
grammar some of the grammar has already
become second nature to me but I do
often often pick up some other things so
I just want to make this point that one
of the major advantages of what appears
to be a passive way of learning is that
you become independent you're not forced
to sit in the classroom where the
teachers gonna have you role-playing and
so or you know I had this great debate
with the Canadian Canadian benchmarks
system which is this thing that has been
developed in Canada over ten years and
up teen committee meetings and people
travelling around the countryside and
and they insist that any immigrant who
is learning English is obliged to learn
as long as the government's paying for
it using a system called task based
learning which means that the learner
sits in the classroom and pretends to be
a nurse or a checkout person in a suit
market or whatever other tasks they
decide the teacher decides or they might
say okay what do you diet would you know
ask the class work do they want to you
know what kind of a task that they want
to act out but the point is that the
decision on what to do in the classroom
is with the teacher and so the big
advantage of input based learning is
that you decide what the learning task
what the learning subject matter is
going to be and that is a big advantage
because if you can develop that ability
to be an independent learner you will
succeed more quickly than if you remain
in the position of a dependent learner
thank you for listening